the Brazilian government is saying no
thank you to an offer of aid from g7
nations to help fight the devastating
forest fires in the Amazon more than 80
thousand fires have been reported in
Brazil this year
now there's renewed concern that further
damage could disrupt global weather
patterns Manuel Bojorquez is in the
Amazon region of Rio Branco Brazil where
it's estimated an area of forest bigger
than a soccer field burns every minute
Manny what are you seeing there well
well we are some rain actually helped to
tamp down the flames but there certainly
has not been enough of it you know the
Amazon is set to contain 15 percent of
the Earth's fresh water and scientists
say all this moisture moisture helps to
cool down the earth the fear is with so
much of the forest burning that it could
cause irreversible damage to the world's
climate the scenes from the Amazon can
be overwhelming forests once teeming
with life claimed by unrelenting flames
it's estimated this year in the Amazon
more than 3,500 square miles of forest
an area roughly the size of Yellowstone
National Park have fallen to fires like
these in Peru people are using whatever
they can shovels even tree branches to
try to smother the flames many of the
fires are believed to be set by farmers
trying to clear land
ssup a clinic is one farmer in Brazil
says these kinds of things happen here
every year we just aren't able to tell
who is responsible
nobody is punished to get a greater
sense of the deforestation we took to
the air from up here you can really see
where humans have been
you to cut into the rainforest there are
plots of land where the trees appear to
be freshly cut all of this to make room
for soybean production in cattle ranches
1020 years ago this was all rain forest
outside Brazilian embassies around the
world protesters have been blasting the
country's president
Jair Bo senado and his administration's
handling of the deforestation and fires
both sanada's administration on Monday
rejected a 20 million dollar pledge from
g7 leaders to help fight the fires
equating the aid to treating Brazil like
a colony major Fabio Pasha who is
helping lead brazil's military
firefighting efforts dismissed the
international criticism there are people
who think that this type of assistance
should have happened a lot faster do you
have anything to say to them no we do
know that it's happening and have taken
action before he said the only
difference is the international
visibility came just now
president bole Senado had said he would
make 44 thousand troops available to
help fight the fires but there are
reports from some areas that the
military presence has been scarce gale
alright man well reporting from Brazil
thank you